جلسه المساءله الاسبوعيه للحكومه
البريطانيه كانت صعبه على رستونا اذا طرح
حزب العمال والوطنين الاسكتلندي خمسه
اسئله تتعلق بمزاعم التهرب الضريبي لناظم
الزهاوي الوزيري من دون حقيبه ورئيس حزب
المحافظين التصعيد الحد ذهب حد وصف رئيس
الحكومه بالضعيف لرفده اقاله الزهراوي
لمصلحه الضرائب
طريقه التعامله مع قضيه الزهاوي بعد نشر
الاخير بيان التسويه ضريبيه تعود للسنوات
بما يقارب خمسه ملايين جنيه في ما قد يكون
خرقا صارخا للقواعد الوزاريه
[موسيقى]
لم تظهر اي مشاكل معي عندما عينته في
منصبه الحالي ومنذ ان علقت على هذا الامر
الاسبوع الماضي طهاره المزيد من المعلومات
ولهذا السبب طلبت من المستشار المستقل
النظر في هذه القضيه الان لا يمكنني الحكم
مسبقا على نتائجها ولكن من الثواب ان نحقق
في هذا الامر بشكل كامل لمعرفه جميع
الحقائق
الذي كان وزير الماليه لشهرين ومسؤول عن
اموال الشعب يعترف بملابسات ضرائب الشخصيه
ولكنه ترك بعض الاسئله من دون اجابه
لاسيما لجهه فاتوره ضرائب مرتبطه باسهم في
شركه الراي شارك الذهاوي في تاسيسها في
العام 2000 لكنه نقل اسهمها المقدره بس 27
مليون جنيه الى شركه مسجله في جبل طارق
باسم والده وينفي الزهاوي ان يكون مستفيدا
في هذه الشركه ويقول ان لا علاقه له بها
معظم الزهاوي يستمر في منصبه بصعوبه بالغه
المعايير الاخلاقيه مثل هو مثل وزير العدل
دومنكراب المتهمين بالتنمر وذلك رغم الضرر
الذي يلحقه بالمستقبل السياسي لرئيس
الحكومه رئيس السوناك مصطفى زارو العربيه
لندن